und nun liebe zuschauer ist es an der
zeit einen menschen zu ehren der uns in
diesem jahr beigebracht hat worauf ist
in der politik wirklich ankommt auf dass
ich christian lindner hat ganz allein
die fdp von den toten zurück geholt und
sie in nur sieben tagen nach seinem
antlitz geformt zu einer ganz neuen
modernen partei die sogar englisch kann
und dann ist da noch das man im prinzip
ebenfalls bürokratieabbau one into out
prinzip was ist das 1 1 1 aus ja ganz
genau
ja genau wann in englisch für 1 schreibt
euch das auf kinder so geht nämlich
marketing auch den ältesten neoliberalen
quark kann man jung und tipp erscheinen
lassen mit der richtigen verpackung
einfache knackige botschaften sind
gefragt gern auch mehrmals
hintereinander die fdp
das ist eine kleine partei wir sind eine
kleine partei er im grunde von beginn an
lahm gewesen
von beginn an lahm wir haben in
deutschland so eine eine lust am
untergang eine lust am untergang und das
sollte uns langsam zum nachdenken
bringen sollte uns zum nachdenken sollte
uns sollte uns wirklich zum nachdenken
ja da hat er ein absolut absolut recht
recht recht
die heute-show verleiht christian
lindner für seinen german mut kurz vor
jamaika die hosen gestrichen voll zu
haben
vor allem aber für seine geilen plakate
den goldenen vollpfosten in der komplett
verspiegelte versionen damit du lieber
christian dich immer sehen kannst
herzlichen glückwunsch
und das hier ist dein lied das land ist
uns egal ich sehe gut aus den fonds aus
ganz deutschland findet mich heiß klar
ist nicht normal ich glücklich